hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's look at
spiral matrix we are given an m by
n matrix and all we need to do is return
all of the elements in spiral order
so the order that we're given the
elements in is one two three
four five six seven eight nine right if
you go from left to right
but we actually wanna return these
elements
in spiral order so we are gonna start at
the top
left and we're going to go 1 we're going
to go right
2 go right again 3 now we can't go
right anymore so now we're going to go
down because that is
spiral order so we're going to do 6 go
down one more time
do nine now go left because we can't go
down anymore
we're gonna get eight go left again
we're gonna get seven
now we can't go left anymore so we go up
to four and if we try to go up now we
actually see well we already visited
that right the one's been visited
so now we actually go right we have the
five and the five
is the last element if we try to go
right we cannot go right anymore
so how can we write an efficient
algorithm to do that right to worry
about
okay we're going in this direction and
then eventually we have to change
directions and all that stuff
well in my opinion the easiest way is
also the most efficient way so one thing
to notice is
we let's say we start at the top left we
go right right right we go here
so we cross out all these elements then
we go down down down
we get here then we go left we go here
so we cross out these elements
and then we go up right so we went all
four directions we went
right we went down we went left
and then we went up until we couldn't
anymore but we still have some elements
left but do you see what we kind of did
here
we took the outermost layer
and shrinked it right so now we have a
sub
rectangle or sub matrix here that now
we're going to do the exact same
algorithm on but you notice that our
boundary
our left boundary was over here and our
right boundary was initially over here
but now we shrinked it right this is our
new sub matrix right originally we had
this
so our left and our new left and right
boundaries
are here right so we shrunk it by one we
had to move
our left and right boundaries inward
similarly we had a
top boundary of here and we had a bottom
boundary
over here but we had to shrink that as
well right we had to move our top
boundary down one and we had to move
our bottom boundary up by one so now our
top boundary is over here and our bottom
boundary is over here
and we still have some elements to go in
spiral order so again what are we going
to do with this
sub matrix well we're going to start at
the top
left which is over here and we're going
to go in spiral order so now we're going
to go
right so we get to seven but notice now
notice now how we pretty much have gone
through all the elements right
and so since we done these elements what
we can now say is our left and right
boundaries were moved
once more right so left and right are
now at the same position
or they've intersected or overlapped or
whatever and so what that basically
means is
we don't really have a rectangle anymore
right our
boundaries are not in a position so
therefore we don't have to continue
going anymore right and you can tell by
the picture well we already visited
every single element
we don't have to continue the spiral
we're just going to repeat
old elements anyway so that's the main
idea but i'm just going to show you
i'm just going to actually walk through
the algorithm and show you a couple
of things that i'm going to do slightly
differently so i am going to initialize
the left boundary over here because this
is our zero
column right and this is our third
column but what i'm actually gonna do is
put the
right boundary over here just mainly
because it's gonna make the code a
little bit easier for us
and so this is the zeroth row and this
is the second row right
so what i'm gonna do is put our top
boundary over here
and i'm gonna put our bottom boundary
not at index two but
one more so i'm gonna put our bottom
boundary over here just because it makes
the code a little bit easier
and so as you can tell basically what
we're doing is we have
four pointers and these four pointers
are going to make co
make coding this solution the spiral
matrix solution a lot easier for us
we are going to start over here because
it's the
position that our top left is pointing
at so we're always going to start at the
top
left position and so we are going to
have an
output we know the output is going to be
a list or an array so we're going to add
1 to our output and then we are going to
go
right so so whenever we start at the top
left we're going to go right because
we're going to do the first
row so now we're going to be at 2 we're
going to add
2 to our output and we're just going to
keep repeating this until we
reach our right boundary our right
boundary is going to tell us when we can
stop
now we get to 3 we add 3 to our output
now we get to 4 we can add 4 to our
output
and now we know we cannot go any further
we've
basically reached our right boundary so
now what we're going to do
is we are going to go down but before we
go
down since we just did this entire row
we added it to the output we don't
really need
this top boundary anymore right but what
can we do with it
we can basically shift it down because
our
new top boundary of our rectangle right
now look at our current rectangle
is this so our top boundary belongs in
this spot so now we are going to go
down we're going to reach this 8 we're
going to add that 8 to our output
and we're going to go down one more time
and we're going to keep going down
until we reach our bottom boundary right
that's pretty
obvious from looking at the picture so
now we reach
our bottom boundary and the last value
is 12.
so now obviously we're gonna start going
left
right but do you notice any differences
about
our matrix now well clearly we just did
this
entire row what does that tell us well
that tells us we can
update our right boundary right because
if you look at the new rectangle
we've we've moved our top boundary over
here but we can also take our right
boundary
and and move our right boundary in this
position right
of course the left and bottom boundaries
can still be the same because look at
our rectangle we need those boundaries
still
but now we are going to go left we reach
an 11 we can add that to our output
we go left again keep going left until
we reach our
left boundary right until we reach the
element at our left boundary but in this
case it's inclusive when we were going
right we were going to stop before we
got to the right boundary
and this is basically just to make the
code easier even though it's
a little bit inconsistent so now we get
a 10
we add that 10 to our output we go left
one more time
we get a 9 and we add that to our output
but now you can see
that this left boundary is where we need
to stop
but as you can see we just finished the
entire bottom row
what does that tell us well our bottom
boundary can be shifted up by one
over here because our new rectangle
is like this right our right boundary
tells us about this our bottom boundary
tells us about
this our top boundary tells us about
this
and our left boundary tells us about
this so this is the resulting rectangle
one by three
so now we're gonna put the bottom
boundary here
and now we're gonna start going up and
we're not just gonna keep going up
forever
we're gonna stop once we reach our top
boundary which is pretty easy
for us because we only have one element
and now we're at the top boundary
so we get a five and we add that to our
output
now you can see that this this problem
has been reduced we took our matrix and
chopped off each side of it we chopped
off the top
the bottom the right column and the left
column
but we can still continue our our
algorithm as it
is the only thing that we have to update
now is take
our left boundary because we just did
the entire left column now
and shift it to the right by one
so now again we're going to start at the
top
left because the top is pointing here
the left is also pointing here
so we're going to start here and we're
going to go right
but we have to add 6 to our output so we
add a 6 to the output
we keep going right until we reach this
boundary right which
we've reached once we've gotten to the
seven so we add the seven to the output
and now we stop because we reached the
right boundary
and since we've just finished this top
row what are we gonna do
we're gonna update the top pointer right
we're going to cross it out and we're
going to shift it
down over here right so now top is over
here
as well as bottom they're both pointing
at the same
row and basically that's the condition
once pointers reach like in this case
top and bottom reach but it could have
been possible that
left and right reach the same position
if
either of those things happen then we
can stop our algorithm because we know
we've
done every single element that we needed
to so now let's get into the code and by
the way the time
complexity of this is big o m by n which
is the dimensions of the matrix
the memory complexity is big o of 1
because we are not saving any extra
memory we're just
running the code and it's big of one if
you do not count the
output as extra memory so we have our
result variable
i'm gonna have the four pointers that we
mentioned left
and right so left is going to be
initially at zero right is going to be
the length of the matrix right is
basically going to be the
number of columns plus one which is
exactly what the length is going to give
us we also have a
top and bottom variable so top is gonna
be zero we know we start at
top left is zero zero the bottom is
going to be
the length of the matrix which is going
to tell us the number of
rows and basically all i'm gonna do is
just keep looping until we know that
either of the pointers cross so we know
that left has to be
less than right we don't want them to
meet each other
and top has to be less than the bottom
so the first thing i'm going to do is go
left to right
and get every single get every value
in the top row so every i in the top row
so i'm just going to iterate for i in
range
left to right and this is basically why
i'm setting the right
uh out of bounds because in python it's
going to go from left which is initially
going to be 0 maybe right is let's say
four
it's gonna it's basically gonna go from
zero to three in this case that's what
python does
the four is non-inclusive so this right
value is non-inclusive
and so for each of these values we know
all we have to do
is append it to our result so
how do we get the value well we know
we're in the top row
so for the row we just put top for the
column we can put
i and since we just completed our top
row before we do anything else let's
update our top variable so if we
increment it by one
basically what we're doing is shifting
top down by one
next i want to get every i in
the right column right the rightmost
column
how can we do that well i'm going to
iterate
i in range from top
to bottom right it's as easy as that and
we are allowed to do this because we
just
incremented our top by one so we're not
going to have any repeated elements
so now i'm just going to take every
single one of these elements
and add it to our result so the row that
we're in
is of course i because we're going from
top to bottom the column that we're in
is right but we're going to subtract by
1 because we know that our right is
actually
out of bounds and so after we do this we
know we just completed the rightmost
column so what can we do we can take our
right variable and decrement it by one
because then we're shifting it to the
left
now this is the part that you're kind of
gonna have to trust me on
so so basically if the pointers have
crossed so if this condition is no
longer true
what we have to do is break out of our
loop
and if you don't understand exactly why
we're doing this i would encourage you
to run
this entire code or at least do it by
hand on a couple examples so imagine our
matrix was
this if we had like a single row matrix
see what happens when you do that or
imagine if we had a
column matrix like this see what happens
when you run this code
so we did the top row and we did the
rightmost column so now we have to do
the bottom row
and we know we have to do this from
right to left so that's going to be a
little annoying so we're going to go
for i in range so we're going to start
at our right boundary
minus 1 because we know our right is
actually a little bit farther to the
right
and we're going to do this from right to
left
but left we're also going to take -1
because that's how python works
the left is non-inclusive so if we
actually want to go
all the way to left we have to subtract
it by one and
to do this in reverse order we just have
to add a negative one
so basically what we're doing is going
from right to left in reverse order so
backwards so now we're going to take
each of these and append it to our
result
so we are in the bottom row so for the
row we're going to take
bottom minus 1 because we know even the
bottom
pointer is actually out of bounds by
just one value
right so this is just an off by one
error and
the column is going to be i that's what
we're doing when we're going from
right to left and so after we've done
this we've just done the bottom row so
we're going to update the bottom
pointer how are we going to update it in
this case we subtract it by
one if we want to shift it upwards so
last but not least we want to get every
i
in the leftmost column right so
we can and we want to do that from
bottom to top
because we are going in spiral order so
for i
in range we're gonna start at the bottom
but we are have we have to subtract it
by one to make sure we don't get
the off by one error and we're gonna go
all the way to top
but we're again going to subtract by one
basically we're doing the same thing
that we just did
up here so we're going from bottom to
top in reverse order
so we add a negative one and now for
each of these elements
we're gonna add it to our result
so matrix the row is going to be i
that's what we're doing when we're
iterating from bottom to top
the column is going to be the leftmost
column and after we've completed this we
are allowed to increment left by one
because we just completed the entire
left column so we're shifting our left
pointer
to the right by one so this is the code
with these comments it makes it seem a
little longer than it actually is but
this code is not too long the only thing
we have to do now is
return the result that we just
computed the array now we can run this
code
and you can see the code is pretty
efficient and
one thing i'll mention is that see we're
kind of repeating
the same thing like four times over here
in total that is only like 12 lines of
code but if you wanted you could put it
in a helper function
but i think in this case a helper
function just makes it more confusing i
prefer to actually
write this out because it's pretty
obvious when you write it out and add a
comment
what exactly we're doing but other than
that i hope this was helpful
i hope it showed you that this problem
can be written in pretty simple code
and if you enjoyed please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon